all that excitement is not halted the
Russia investigation or inquiries into
misconduct at the FBI either the House
Judiciary Committee has now subpoenaed
former FBI lore lawyer Lisa page to
appear for a closed-door interview on
Wednesday Paige exchanged numerous texts
of course attacking the president with
her lover Peter struck the FBI agent
who's in the middle of a lot of these
stories meanwhile Paul man affords
attorneys have made a new court filing
that reveals there was a 20-17 meeting
between DOJ officials and Associated
Press journalists suggesting grand jury
secrecy may have been violated
Molly Hemingway is a senior editor at
the Federalist she joins us now I'm good
to see you Molly great to be here with
you let's start with Lisa page
Peter Struck's already appeared behind
closed doors we expect him I believe in
public later this week what do we know
about Lisa page and why she's being
brought in right Lisa page was Andrew
McCabe's legal consigliere she was his
trusted confidant Andrew McCabe being
the fired number two at the FBI he was
fired for not being truthful about his
communications with reporters she was
implicated in those although she was
authorized to talk to the reporters but
we have all these texts showing just
extreme bias between these two agents as
it related to the both the Clinton
investigations and the Trump
investigation and we do not have good
answers from her about exactly what was
going on and so it's a really exciting
opportunity that Congress will be asking
her the insurance policy to maybe
prevent Donald Trump from being elected
president the idea of a meeting in
quote-unquote Andy's office long a you
know expected anticipated that that
meant Andy McCabe who you mentioned was
the number two at the FBI and Paige's
boss and not just that there were
interesting texts about the White
House's role in the whole investigation
and just the decisions that were played
that were made about the use of
confidential informants of which there
were you know many and there's just so
much that remains to be learned about
what was going on now she left under
pressure so it's it's a particularly
interesting thing that she will be she
left the FBI under pressure and so are
the DOJ and let's talk about Paul
Manafort
legal team has been quite frustrated
that he's been thrown in jail before his
trial on tax and other charges because
of alleged witness tampering he's now in
solitary confinement
confinement to protect him because they
believe that his lawyers do that he's
going to get beaten up people think he's
a trophy because he was close to
President trumpet it's very disturbing
and troubling and now we learned that
maybe ap journalists were getting inside
information and grand jury secrecy might
have been violated there is a really
interesting story about this meeting
that the Department of Justice had with
these AP reporters and neither side
comes out looking particularly good
given the information we have thus far
the DOJ appears to have been sharing
information that came out of grand jury
proceedings that's strictly against the
rules but the AP there their argument
seems to be well we weren't sharing
information we were collecting
information from reporters well that
violates every journalistic norm if it's
true that the Associated Press was
sharing information if they'd become
activists or informants that's not
typical behavior for journalists all
right a lot more digging to come on that
story for sure
I'll have anyway appreciate your time
thank you